in previous videos we've gone into
reasonable depth
on the narrative of how the sikh
religion was started
initially by guru nanak and then how it
developed under the next gurus all the
way until the 10th guru and finally
as it was compiled in the guru granth
sahib which is considered by sikhs
to be the last and final guru sikhism is
oftentimes compared to both hinduism
and islam sometimes with reference to
the idea that
it has elements of both while others
would argue that no it is a completely
independent religion
and any similarity is just coincidental
so let's tackle that
central question what elements of
continuity does sikhism
represent and in this video we're going
to think about
continuity in terms of religious
continuity
and in particular does it have elements
from islam
or hinduism in it so we could first
focus on
some of the cultural trappings or some
of the historical trappings
of sikhism and think about the
connections to
both hinduism and islam the first
obvious connection
is that guru nanak the first guru and
many of the early gurus
grew up in hindu families
but there are also cultural connections
to islam the sikh
religion emerges in punjab which is
where or near the various muslim rulers
of the time
held their capitals well they're talking
about the dali sultanate which was in
power for over 250 years when
sikhism started to emerge with guru
nanak but also the mogul empire which
really developed in its early stages at
the same time that sikhism develops so
many of the followers of
sikhism were both hindu and muslim
a lot of the terminology of sikhism
borrows words and borrows ideas from
both
islam and hinduism the word allah
is used to refer to god in parts of the
guru granth sahib
but so is the word rama one of the
first and closest followers of guru
nanak who was with him
most of his life was bhai mardana
and even today many pictures of guru
nanak
would have bhai mardana in them guru
nanak famously
as someone who is spiritually precocious
and spiritually curious
traveled through india and persia and
the middle east
so he visited many temples
but there's also many historic accounts
of him going to mecca and performing
hajj
the guru granth sahib which is
considered the spiritual book the 11th
and final groove for the six
of the contributors to them you have
kabir who
grew up in a muslim family he lived
either around the time of guru nanak or
in the century before guru nanak and
would write about both allah and ram
although he was often critical of both
hinduism and islam
and you also have sheikh farid who was a
muslim
sufi writer and spiritual figure and he
has also contributed to the guru granth
sahib
there's also important rituals that come
from hinduism
so for example when sikhs pass away like
hindus
they are cremated so just looking at
this list
you immediately see that there's
definitely cultural elements whether
we're talking about words whether we're
talking about rituals
whether we're talking about even just
the historical narrative of how and
where sikhism started
that are closely tied to ideas of
hinduism
and closely tied to ideas of islam but
now let's look at the scripture itself
and see if we can
glean any more similarities or
differences
this is the mool mantra which means main
mantra or the basic teaching of sikhism
and it comes from guru nanak and this is
an english translation you'll see
variations of this
but it essentially says one universal
creator
god the name is truth
creative being personified no fear no
hatred
image of the undying beyond birth
self-existent by guru's grace
throughout the guru granth sahib and
much of the writings of especially guru
nanak
focus on devotion to god the one
universal god and so many of you might
think well that seems to have
connections to islam
but you could say well even in hinduism
although there are many aspects of god
the various deities
but there's this notion of a fundamental
reality of brahman
so maybe it has elements of that or
maybe this is just independently
developed but there definitely are parts
of the guru granth
sahib which seem to have elements that
are close to islam
this is a quote from guru nanak he is
allah
the unknowable the inaccessible
all-powerful and merciful creator
so one argument is he's using the arabic
word for god he's using allah
now another argument counter argument
would be well he's just using the
language that
his followers knew and many of his
followers were muslim and so would have
used the word allah for god
but he is not saying that it necessarily
has to be the exact
concept of god as in islam now this is
from
kabir someone sets up a stone idol and
all the world worships it as the lord
those who hold to this belief will be
drowned in the river of darkness and
this is in the guru granth sahib
this notion of being against idol
worship comes out very clear
in this quotation and that is another
idea that is often associated with islam
but as i mentioned there's also many
parallels with hinduism
in the first video on sikhism i give you
this quote from guru nanak the world is
a drama
staged in a dream which alludes to the
hindu notion of
maya the physical reality is is all an
illusion we want to pierce through that
veil
what should the yogi have to fear trees
plants and
all that is inside and outside is
he himself so this is an idea that we
get very clearly from the upanishads
any notion of duality of me being
different from you or even one versus
god
it's all an illusion all is one
by the karma of past actions the robe of
this physical body is obtained
by his grace the gate of liberation is
found
so clear references to the hindu notions
of karma
that action drives consequences that you
enter one physical body after another
but that's not your true self the robe
of this physical body there's a true
self and eventually through the grace of
the ultimate reality
you might be able to have liberation
have moksha
so clear hindu parallels as well one
angle is that guru nanak and sikhism
was attempting a reformation of both
taking elements
that were compelling in either and then
purifying them making them more internal
focused
less focused on ritual less focused on
the external and more focused
on meditation and the true self there's
a lot of quotations in reference to both
religions that make it clear that
it was something different and is
critical of at least how both
religions seemed to be practiced in
india
at that time guru nanak famously said
there is no hindu there is no mussuman
most people feel that he's saying this
distinction that we make between human
beings based on these belief systems
that these are superficial that these
are to some degree
transient that we are all part of the
universal part of the ultimate
reality part of god this is from guru
arjan
the muslim god allah and the hindu god
parbram
are one and the same so here
trying to unify these ideas this is in a
context where many of the followers are
muslim and many are hindu and putting it
in words that they understand
my body and breadth of life belong to
allah to rama
the god of both so once again it's this
bhakti this devotional aspect
surrendering to god
and using the terminology that would be
familiar to people
in that time and in that space
so i encourage you go out there research
think about it for yourself
sikhism for sure has its own unique
identity
and pretty much every religion is a
product of the context in which it
emerged
and has elements from other religions
whether or not that was done
intentionally whether or not it's chance
there does seem to be parallels we can
make a whole tree of religions if we
like
if we put sikhism right here the
question mark of
this video is you have this narrative of
islam
to what degree does it influence sikhism
and many would say that especially the
sufi orders of islam
have much to do with sikhism sufism is
the school of islam
that is more inward looking that is
about devotional love
to god and that's what a lot of sikhism
is focused on
but as mentioned one could also think
about hinduism which is much older than
pretty much any other living religion
today
and in other videos we talk about the
bhakthi movement which is about
devotional
love to god there's also a school of
thought in hinduism known as vedanta
which is more focused on the core
spiritual ideas of the upanishads the
notion of
the ultimate self the ultimate reality
escaping from the cycle of births and
deaths from samsara achieving liberation
moksha
all of these ideas are in sikhism and to
make the point clear that all of our
major religions are connected to each
other
we can keep drawing this tree we talk
about how buddhism brings out
of hinduism that buddha was a hindu and
it might have been
reaction to some of the ritual and the
caste that buddha saw in hinduism or at
least in hindu culture
in fact some of those same motivations
might have motivated guru nanak
islam we talk about in other videos
famously emerges from a judeo-christian
tradition
the most important prophets in islam
after muhammad
are jesus moses and abraham and
christianity of course
comes out of a jewish tradition jesus
was jewish
and one could say that there is even
some direct connections between judaism
and islam
notions of not eating pork notions of
halal
and kosher ideas of circumcision
and one could even argue that judaism
and islam also have close ties to
zoroastrianism
a very ancient monotheistic religion and
cyrus the great of persia was the one
who really spread
zoroastrianism and he's considered a
messiah amongst the jewish people
because he liberated them from the
babylonian captivity
helped them resettle in jerusalem and
helped rebuild the temple at jerusalem
zoroastrianism also has ties to islam
zoroastrians pray five times a day just
like muslims they have the ritual
bathing
before the prayer just like muslims at
the same time of day
so once again amongst all of these
religions they definitely came in
contact with each other and you
definitely have ideas
that are shared amongst the religions so
with that
i'll leave you with one last quote from
guru nanak
and this one would arguably be addressed
to his muslim followers
but it gives you a sense of his trying
to bring people back to the internal
trying to make people less focused on
external ritual
external physical reality and more on
internal
goodness and your actions being more
important than your words or your
rituals
make kindness your mosque sincerity your
prayer carpet
what is just and lawful your quran
modesty your circumcision civility or
fasting
so shalt thou be a muslim or muslim
make right conduct your kaaba making
reference to
the pilgrimage site muslims go to and
pray towards
truth your spiritual guide good works
your creed and your prayer
the will of god your rosary and god will
preserve your honor
guru nanak